brought to you by buyer shook the
collection the world of rapture we
entered our lives last week as part of
the buyer shot collection and while I'm
generally not a big fan of Remus's
rapture is one of my favorite places to
visit in gaming so I'm seriously
considering a second slightly higher
definition trip under the sea since Wes
wanted by the Bioshock collection this
week I thought we'd take a look at some
of the most memorable video game well
I'm not sure I've ever had as much
trouble narrowing down one of these
lists as I did with this video video
game worlds are so often dense beautiful
and unique there are so many outstanding
examples like the post-apocalyptic
wastes to fall out the scrolling Milky
Way galaxy and Mass Effect the imposing
and ominous city 17 in half-life 2 and
the detailed high fantasy locations of
The Witcher obviously since I've
mentioned them now those ones aren't on
my list and neither are a bunch of other
seriously worthy contenders but here are
five of my favorites first up let's talk
Final Fantasy 7 sky ax and its main city
Mitka Midgar is a bubbling city hub in
the midst of an industrial revolution
the technologically advanced metropolis
is perhaps showcased best in the opening
cinematic this shows off the sheer size
and scale of city while Final Fantasy
has plenty of locations worth writing
home about like Lake Prussia and the
Carlin's midgar's stunning cityscape
encompasses everything from downtrodden
slums to the bustling war market and the
massive Shinra headquarters skyscraper
it's really something else next up we
have the continent of Tamriel in the
Elder Scrolls world of NIMH now we could
split hairs over Mara Windsor Adele and
Skyrim if you want to but they're all
pretty bloody great oh the scrolls games
offer up huge open worlds that you can
traverse while watching the landscape
changing under your feet they're filled
with all sorts of stories people
creatures and perhaps my favorite thing
the glorious cities the towering peaks
of Markov the elegance of solitude and
the hidden nooks and crannies of cram
bread in Riften
are all absolu
léa stamped into my mind venturing up to
the throat of the world or down into the
breathtakingly beautiful black reach is
white unreal well and truly earns its
place on this list this probably won't
come as a revelation to you but Doc
Souls is hot doc Souls is hot and I have
a temper so suffice it to say I haven't
played a lot of it that's said I have
watched the entire thing played through
because the world is just so enticing
peppered with the most horrifying
creatures your darkest nightmares can
conjure up the McCobb Dark Souls takes
place in Lordran Lordran is unforgiving
and grim filled with nasty things that
want to kill you and some gorgeous
environmental and architectural design
which you'll be able to fully appreciate
while you're returning to collect souls
for the 19th time all figuring out where
you're supposed to go next
Freeland that's so unwelcoming and cruel
the dark beautiful game worlds makes it
absolutely worth seeing what's beyond
the next bus no list about unforgettable
game worlds would be complete without a
mention of World of Warcraft's Azeroth
Azeroth is an absolute monster of a game
world it always needed to be big given
its home to the most popular MMO for
time but it's also especially rich and
diverse Azeroth is the quintessential
fantasy world filled with stories
memorable characters and dozens of
vastly different environments from the
beautiful purple spire Laden city of
Dalaran
to the sweeping plains of necron Azeroth
is also fallen victim to the
world-changing events of a cataclysm
expansion which massively altered the
landscape to have a world compelling
enough to call leagues of heroes back
into the fray every time a new expansion
lands is a tall order but the
ever-evolving in detail rich World of
Warcraft seems to have nailed it four
down one to go and of course it's Hyrule
the setting for one of the greatest hero
narratives ever told in gaming The
Legend of Zelda series has seen hyrule
change a lot and when we got our first
taste of the iconic location in 3d upon
the release of ocarina of time
most people were pretty understandably
flawed okay so it's pretty old now but
two locations like the Goron cities or
as domain and the Lost
or inspiring and the exploration of HS
underpinned with one of the best
soundtracks in all of gaming stepping
out into hyrule field still instills
that feeling of wonder and both Wind
Waker and Twilight Princess proves that
even the flooded and corrupted
iterations of Hyrule are equally
enchanting those are all my picks but do
let me know which ones I missed out on
down in that comment section and happy
adventuring